they are asking us to gamble
our residents jobs homes and businesses
and a large chunk of our economy on a
strategy
that their own experts tell them might
not work
we would never sign up for that
while this is not necessarily greater
manchester's view
the deputy chief medical officer also
told us last night that the only certain
thing to work
is a national lockdown but the
government told us this morning it is
unwilling to do that because of the
damage it will do to the national
economy and yet that is what they want
to impose
on the north so that was our conclusion
from the number 10 meeting this morning
they are willing to sacrifice jobs and
businesses here
to try and save them elsewhere
greater manchester the liverpool city
region
and lancashire are being set up as the
canaries in the coal mine
for an experimental regional lockdown
strategy
as an attempt to prevent the expense of
what is truly needed
the very least they should be offering
the people of greater manchester
who will be affected by these closures
is
a full and fair eighty percent furlough
scheme
for all affected workers 80 percent
income support for people who are
self-employed
and a proper compensation scheme for
businesses
so far they have not been prepared to
offer
that imposing damaging
regional lockdowns in this way won't
work
it will level down the regions and make
recovery here
longer and harder to those who say this
is all politics
let me remind you that ten weeks ago
myself
two deputy mayors and all the leaders
became the first in the country to work
with the government
in accepting regional restrictions and
the people here
have been strongly struggling under them
ever since
this is an important moment
greater manchester will stand firm
we are fighting back for fairness and
for the health of our people in the
broadest sense